once you finish running the pipeline you  can take a look at the various outputs  in the download folder here we can see  several output files including  enrichment analysis and GAC analysis  outputs in toxic format as well as  visualization plots including ma plot  and volcano plot if you scroll below we  can also look at other graphs and see  what they say about our samples for  instance we have the heat map as well as  an interactive volcano plot with  significantly expressed dreams depicted  in red color finally we also have an  external dashboard that allows all the  tables and graphs to be maintained in a  shareable format this also contains all  the important graphs and tables such as  volcano plot heat map that we have  previously described